the thai navy seals put everything they
had into it but only this group of
people who do it as a weekend hobby has
those skills
that's from the rescue one of the
documentaries along with numerous books
that detailed the race to save a boy's
soccer team trapped in a flooded cave in
thailand
now four years later oscar-winning
director ron howard has put his lens on
the drama in 13 lives
news coverage of the search and rescue
inside that mountainous cave in northern
thailand showed the intensity of the
mission to save those 13 souls
but few knew just how extraordinary the
global effort truly was i was aware of
the event but you know we didn't we
didn't pursue it and action director ron
howard admits he didn't that is until an
official script crossed his desk and
once i corroborated that the writer
wasn't making stuff up that you know all
of these twists and turns had really
occurred i thought well that's that's
very active boys i felt like that's a
movie well i was in thailand at the time
and but thai film producer raymond pathe
navi ragoon knew the story had big
screen potential what i didn't know was
that i would be one of the people who
was helping run outward making you know
the film out of it
takes a certain kind of mindset for the
deep cave diving you have to be a bit
nuts
13 lives goes inside the tom luang cave
and the frantic effort to reach the 12
boys and their coach that's it we better
head back there was no guarantee
whatsoever
of a successful outcome
and yet
people
just decided to give it everything that
they had you're talking about the five
hour dime it took a village and then
some
local volunteers thai navy seals and a
team of elite british cave divers
they can't see
they have to feel their way along
they have to trust that when they've
wriggled into something that they're
going to be able to back out they have
to trust that their gear is going to
work
it's like trying to get somewhere where
no human being is supposed to be able to
go
there were moments when i was sitting
there thinking like oh my god get out
get out far more involved you know i've
done stuff with fire
houston we have a problem
i've done weightlessness
i've done formula one races
a lot of stuff with horses that can be
very dangerous i learned all the way
back on apollo 13
that it actually demands
every bit of your technique
and in all the creativity you can muster
to tell one of these stories and have it
look like it's just unfolding even more
so
with 13 lives
two of the divers played by actors colin
farrell and viggo mortensen find the
boys miles inside the cave but without a
plan to get them out
howard leaned on his team of set
designers and cinematographers to
recreate that dangerous journey
their stats but at the end of the day
they were little tiny caves and they're
still submerged
and the two real life rescuers
hired as technical advisers to train
them they all reminded everyone that it
doesn't take very long to drown
these are still human beings submerged
and pinned and trapped they all admitted
later
that they all had moments where they
really felt like they were in a little
bit of trouble but they worked their way
through it in the spirit of the training
which they were given and they never
told me about it because they know i
would have probably freaked out and said
well then we got to get this done people
in here johnny okay
yeah i'm okay just give me a minute
that attention to detail was shown
through all aspects of the film
from the portrayal of local customs to
the specific lingual dialects native to
the families living in the region so you
were taking on this movie
which was not one in your native tongue
two not in your native land at a time
when a lot of folks were talking about
appropriation right i really weighed
this you know and i felt well at the end
of the day this is an international
story i'm just going to work hard to
make those who are skeptical
uh i hope i can earn their respect at
the end through through the effort
actually i think it's really to ron's
credit that you know we didn't even have
a conversation like oh how much tie is
there if you see the film it's like
nearly 30 40 in thai
and these conversations never happened
because it was like well this is just
what happened in real life
our duties was to really capture what is
you know the most accurate and the most
authentic and i think that that was
something that you know i felt really
gratified because you know he put that
trust in me but he also put that trust
in you know the crew to really execute
howard meticulously lets the daring
rescue unfold for audiences what are you
thinking
just a crazy idea one that had never
been tried before and seemed destined to
fail so you are expecting casualties
yes
it's been four years since all 13 made
it out of the cave alive raymond tell me
is there any lingering trauma what can
you tell us about the real people today
well the interesting thing is you know
vern unswerved he's the british resident
in thailand who called uh all the cave
drive divers to come so he took five of
the kids
back into the cave
for like 24 hours what and apparently
they actually enjoyed the trip it was
almost nostalgic for them people would
feel very traumatized very distraught if
you're in the west but in thailand they
really believed in meditation which is
you know something that we felt was
really important in you know to show in
the film oh that that was key yeah huge
key on behalf of our coach we are
staying strong he teach us to
meditate i guess the takeaway is
we are at our best
things are at their worst yeah what
happened
this is a case where it just brought out
the best in all of them
all the boys are fired it's a
fascinating story great talk
this was an 18 day rescue the fact that
they were able to to outlast
having no food no water no real like
drinking water but but this is a huge
reveal how they got those children out
of the cave and that's the secret to the
story um that i didn't want to kind of
yeah don't tell me everything no i know
i know two of the divers two of the navy
seals uh did die in this in this rescue
and they are thailand heroes
it is an amazing story and i hope you
both get a chance to watch it last night
i thought it was great